this is hilarious as you know there are
really no objective truths for the Trump
administration someone is a good person
to Trump as long as they serve Trump's
interests and say the right things about
Trump and as soon as they don't they're
no longer good people in fact they're
liars they're terrible people we saw it
with Michael Cohen we saw it with so
many people I can't even give you the
entire list it's sort of what I I'm
increasingly calling this stupid
post-modernism and it's something we're
seeing from the right on everything from
fact to opinion and I already told you
earlier that Donald Trump's campaign
chairman Paul Manafort has flipped he's
now working with Robert Muller he
presumably has valuable information to
provide about other people of interests
so within minutes of mana fork flipping
the White House revised the statement
that said they believe Paul Manafort is
going to be telling the truth to
investigators just like that no more
truth-telling from Manta Ford as
expected by Trump Trump's lawyer Rudy
Giuliani had put out this statement
initially when News was sort of nebulous
but breaking about what was going on
with metaphors end quote once again an
investigation has concluded with a plea
having nothing to do with President
Trump or the Trump campaign the reason
the President did nothing wrong and Paul
Manafort will tell the truth that was
rudy giuliani statement within minutes
they realized wait a second we don't
want to say that mana Ford is
cooperating with Muller he's going to be
saying a lot of presumably really
horrible things to Muller about what
Trump and others did so then they revise
the statement and they put out an almost
identical version except it removes one
key line saying quote once again an
investigation has concluded with a plea
having nothing to do with President
Trump or the Trump campaign the reason
the president did nothing wrong of
course completely gone from this new
statement that Paul Manafort is going to
tell the truth but then of course
Trump's team was asked well you put out
the first statement which said Manta
Ford's going to tell the truth then
minutes later you put out a second
statement which no longer says men if
it's going to tell the truth do you no
longer believe that Paul Manafort is
going to tell the truth and they did not
respond to that request for comment
think back just a few days when Donald
Trump tweeted that quote unlike Michael
Cohen he meaning Manafort refused to
quote break that was seen as a sign of
mana Ford's strengths and his
credibility make no mistake the Trump
administration sees that the walls are
closing in noting that Trump or his
administration say should be believed
about this and we need to go merely by
the legal events charges evidence guilty
pleas guilty verdicts people who are
cooperating despite the fact that we
were told that there was no case against
them whatsoever and this is actually a
really interesting lesson to me about
how to handle crises and how to manage
negative press and how not to manage it
because I've been saying from the
beginning that the entire Trump Russia
thing from the very start it is
significantly self-inflicted and what I
mean by that is that from the first day
there was the idea that maybe there's
going to be an investigation from that
day on if Donald Trump instead of
obviously trying to obstruct insulting
people on Twitter drawing even more
attention to his actions and the actions
of his family and his campaign staffers
and cronies if instead of all of that
stuff Trump had just said I am very busy
being president I will fully cooperate
with the investigation I look forward to
being cleared and in the meantime I'm
going to advance the agenda that I
promised voters I'm not saying if he had
done that there would never have been an
investigation because clearly he became
this erratic when news of the
investigation started to spread it would
not have been nearly as bad and in
particular the firing of coaming right
if he had done everything the same but
not fired Comey this never would have
gotten as far as it did sort of hard to
imagine that thinking back now but there
were
countless moments where Trump could have
gun Trump could have gone in a different
direction and of course now it's too
little too late but this should be yeah
I don't know if they have classes in
college about crisis management but if
they do this mishandling of this entire
Fiasco with Trump at the very top of
that Mis handling and of course people
around him that haven't done a
particularly good job this should be
sort of like crisis management 101 what
not to do send me your thoughts about
what you think this entire palm Anna
Ford flipping cooperation deal means I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show we've got a
good one for you today I'm glad you're
with us one of today's sponsors is
Skillshare which is an incredible online
learning community offering over 10,000
high-quality online courses on a huge
variety of topics the first 500 people
who click the link under this video will
get two entire months of totally free
access to every single class offered by
Skillshare you'll have free access to
courses on music art photography
business computer programming cooking
meditation and everything in between I
think you'll have no problem finding
courses that are perfect for you I just
took a really fascinating class on
watercolor painting which I am not yet
at the level of trying to perfect but
more the level of trying to learn even
just a little bit about our show is
giving you two entire months of totally
free access to every course offered by
Skillshare risk free if you click the
link under this video you'll have two
whole months to take classes on anything
you're passionate about classes taught
by real people who share your passion
and after that you can keep getting
access to the entire site for less than
ten bucks a month
just click the link under this video to
redeem your to three months of skill
share but hurry because it's only
available to the first 500 people who
sign up